so a few days ago I posted this image
online because I saw it and I was kind
of charmed by it and I want to explain
why that is and then I'm gonna solve it
for you so I was tried by this image
because it belongs to a category of
things that get posted every now and
then like every a few months one of
these seems to go around and usually
these things actually drive me crazy
I call them emoji math puzzles and I'm
not the only person who calls them that
if you go to Google and you search for
emoji math puzzles you'll see all these
different variations unlike you know
smiley faces and flowers and fairies and
all the rest and essentially it's just
algebra right it's just symbols that are
in place of numbers and then you have to
solve something it's a system of
simultaneous equations is what we would
call that if we wanted to be fancy just
as a sort of side note one of the
funniest things is if you go and search
for emoji math puzzles you know there's
Google and it autocompletes what you
want thinks you're searching for and the
only thing more popular than emoji math
puzzles is emoji math puzzles with
answers which I think it sort of is
hilarious and it sort of gets to the
bottom of why I want to show you the
answer for this and I should have
predicted this when I posted this in a
bunch of different places there was well
let's just say lots of confusion about
what the answer should be and it's true
there is some ambiguity built into the
puzzle which I don't like so I'm going
to show you different answers that are
possible some answers are not possible
I'm gonna show you the different
alternatives and then I'm gonna try and
make a case for why one of them is
probably the true answer the one that
was intended by whoever created this
puzzle so let's have a look at it now to
start with what I'm gonna do is rather
than see on this emoji here I am going
to be like a normal mathematician I'm
gonna replace all these symbols with
much simpler symbols takes me a long
time to draw a bee emoji or a pizza
emoji for that matter so I'm gonna use
some pronumerals some letters so instead
of the beer icon
let's choose blue that are we should be
nice and clear instead of the icon I'm
going to use the letter A instead of the
hamburger I'm going to use the letter N
instead of that ice cream you can see
down the bottom I'm going to use the
letter X and I'm not going to ascribe a
letter to the pizza just yet you'll see
why in a few moments so what we're going
to do is rather than write down the
whole thing with these new pronumerals
I'm actually just going to step through
the puzzle from the top down through the
bottom because that's kind of the order
that's logical and it actually makes it
a bit easier for us so let's start off
by having a look at the first and the
easiest line if I were to write this
with just letters I would be using a
plus a plus a and that would be equal to
3 so before we get to the next line I
think most people are pretty happy to
say okay well there's three lots of a
thing and that equals three so I could
write this as three a equals three and
most people are pretty content to say
okay therefore a equals one no surprises
there everyone is on the same page let's
take that value for a for the beer and
let's put that into the next line so
there's a limit here so if I write down
the next line is limit I'm gonna write
that hamburger as an N instead of a
hamburger as n approaches infinity and
now I'm gonna write you know instead of
beer or a I'm going to use the number
that I know a is equal to which is one
so what I've got inside the bracket is
one plus one over there's a hamburger so
that's that's n or to the power of n and
that apparently equals the Peter now
here's the thing and again there's some
knowledge that is required here to be
able to look at this and quickly solve
it as opposed to like doing it from
first principles this result here is
actually kind of among mathematicians
it's a famous result and this what
you've got in here is kind of like a
compound interest situation right like
you might be familiar with hey actually
a rat the a first a equals P outside of
one plus R to the N that's a compound
interest formula and essentially what
you're looking at here is kind of a
variation on that now when you take n as
it goes to infinity what you're
essentially saying is this R here which
is like your interest rate it's getting
very very
small its approaching zero because one
over a very very large number is a very
tiny number so you're getting a very
small amount of interest but then what's
happening is the index up here n over
here that's going towards infinity so
even though you're getting a very tiny
amount of interest you're getting it a
lot of times so we're this often comes
up is if you were changing the
compounding period of a compound
interest loan if for example you had an
interest rate of let's put some numbers
in here let's go with say 5% I'm even
just gonna write 0.05 let's suppose that
was our interest rate and then I asked
you what happens in a year that would be
our R and that will be our n but as I
increase the compounding period like if
I said well let's do this every month
instead of once a year you wouldn't get
5% interest every month you would get
1/12 of that but then the upshot is you
get that interest applied 12 times so
that's why the index would become 12 and
I could repeat this as many times as I
like if I wanted to say make the
compounding period every day and then I
would say you would divide the interest
by 365 and you would change the index to
365 so the limit of this as n approaches
infinity is this result up the top here
and it's a famous result result I'm you
can go ahead actually you can go ahead
and try and put numbers into your
calculator or in a spreadsheet put in
very large values of n and very quickly
you will find that if you put the same
value in this denominator as you do in
this index the values converge really
fast to this particular value 2.71828
dot there's an infinite number of
decimal places off the end there this is
not just any now but it's a special
number this 2.718 etc is equal to e so
this number here sometimes called
Euler's number it's a number that's
attached to exponential growth this is
the number which sort of makes the final
line and the hardest part of this all
click together so you can see why I
didn't describe a letter to the pizza it
gets a letter just by solving what its
value is I'm gonna call it 8 that 2.718
now it's how I look at the final line
which is an integral okay so I'm gonna
combine all the bits and
that I had from before so I've got this
integral from Ln so that's the natural
log for anyone who hasn't met that
before and then there's the pizza right
so that's e which I just worked out from
the previous line so I'm gonna write
natural log of e and then if you look
closely this is where the ambiguity
sneaks in okay there's another natural
log as the upper limit of your integral
but then trap for young players and this
is part of what I hate about most of
these kinds of puzzles often the mass is
actually not the focus it's just kind of
looking closely like you've got to have
better eyesight than mathematical
ability to solve these that's not one
beer emoji that's two beer emoji so what
does this mean and there's lots of
different ways like you can just
interpret this however you like I've
seen people trying to solve this and I'm
them saying oh well
one beer emoji one beer emoji it must be
one times one so that's equal to 1/2
beer emoji is the same as one beer emoji
because if you're multiplying you get
the same value it's probably more
natural to say well it's maybe one plus
one so that would be two and then still
others I've seen well they would argue
that because you've just got to be
remote jeez next to each other I can't
believe I'm having such an involved
argument that beer emojis but anyway
there's no operation between them so it
would just be those two numbers
concatenated together which be a 1 and a
1 so maybe it should be an 11 now what
I'm going to do is I'm going to proceed
as if it were two and I'm gonna make an
argument for later on as to why that is
probably the nicest neatest answer and
the answer that was originally intended
but we will have a look at what results
from the other two answers